let's put it to the test let's do it do
you have any plans for the money a
little more mustache groomings with a
beard like that all things are possible
yes
well garrett davey congratulations the
two of you guys are moving forward into
round three of the competition where we
send you to your home forges to build
one of these two weapons from our forged
and fire vault so you've got the choice
between anvil number one
and anvil number two pick your poison
well i've been standing at anvil number
two since this competition started
there's an old saying from texas you
dance with the one that brung ya number
two
all right the weapon you'll be building
in round three is
the pura sword oh garrett that means
you've got the choice between the pure
sword or this
the chorus sword
so what's it going to be
hera doing the pure as well
featured in season seven of fortune fire
the pira is an ornate versatile sword
used by the yakan tribe in the southern
philippines the weapon's unique blade
shape and long pommel proved to be
challenging for both smiths who were
ultimately forced to start over the
third day of their builds
ultimately one smith was unable to
secure the mechanical connection to her
handle in time forcing the judges to
issue a vote of no confidence due to
safety concerns basements welcome to the
kill test
to find out how lethal your weapons are
according to its historic design i'm
going to take your weapon and deliver
some lethal blows on whatever is behind
the curtain i'm going to find out how
effective your weapons are at the same
time how they feel when i wield them
garrett you're first you ready for this
yep let's do this
[Music]
all right guys let's talk about your
pita sword here your handle construction
well done
your edge is very sharp it allows me to
cut deeply and swing well with your
weapon overall sir
you will kill thank you all right davey
are you set sir you're next yes sir
all right davey let's talk about your
pita sword here first up in your design
it's a very forward heavy weapon as you
can see just by looking at the spine
it's thicker and tapers down
to the guard now your edge
is sharp with a forward weight it chops
into the pig carcass but slicing
not quite because you have to control
the weight of the weapon but
it will kill yeah will
gentlemen you know what time it is the
mystery strength test
now these strength tests are not
concerned about what your blades do to
the target more what that target does to
your blades
garrett you're up first are you ready
let's do it okay
damn the guard the weld all right yeah
[Music]
so garrett
right off i liked the feel of the weapon
the balance was nice the weight was nice
i had no issues looking at that break
your grain structure is beautiful all i
can really say is that that tang is a
little on the lean side and maybe that
where this married up there was just
enough movement in there
that it allowed it to blow apart as as
opposed to being tight and held together
but it definitely felt like a nice
weapon thank you
garrett that is painful to see man but
you are not out of the fight yet
davey your blade has to survive one
strike on this brutal test and if you do
you win
dave
i did not want to see garrett's blade
destroyed
i am really nervous now because he's
going to go up there and try to break my
sword
anything can happen at this point
[Music]
all right davey man there's a lot of
weapon here your grinds are beautiful i
think your handle's beautiful and
comfortable
there's no end to damage on this at all
awesome i would not run my finger down
this blade
you nailed the heat treat on that good
job thank you
well davey the bell is rung and you
survived it man congratulations
garrett we hate to see this happen we
always want to see more testing done but
unfortunately your blade did break
during the test and we can't continue
third reason today you are not the
fortune fire champion
i want to say thank you for coming out
and i have to ask you please leave the
forge man
thanks
thank you
davey your blade survived the test and
that makes you the fortune fire champion
you're gonna be leaving here with a
check for ten thousand dollars man
congratulations thank you
you have any plans for the money a
little more mustache grooming stuff
i am so elated right now thank you so
much knowing where my journey started
when i didn't know anything about
swinging hammers and forging metal
dad
i'm the new forged and fire champion i'm
coming home a winner
[Music]
the tabar shish park
the tabar shishbar is an extremely rare
weapon that was used by mounted warriors
in india pakistan and afghanistan during
the 16th and 1700s the combination of
two deadly weapons the tabar's axe was
sharp and lethal while the shish bar's
mace was just as dangerous using blunt
force to take down opponents
the mace could also contain up to eight
flanges that were able to penetrate
shields and bash through armor making
this brutal weapon a force to be
reckoned with
bladesmiths the tabar shishbar is one
weapon with multiple personalities
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do i will take you to bar
shush bart and use both ends to deliver
killing blows on this ballistics dummy
mark you up first you ready
let's see it let's do this
[Music]
omar
it is sharp
that chopped right into the chest cavity
breaking the bone
this axe dug in and gutted him
your mace definitely will crush you can
see the breaking bones inside
your weapon will kill
thank you
chris you ready i am let's do this
oh my gosh
into the lung into the heart
your mace definitely penetrated through
just go
bones
are broken i don't think it's gonna end
well
your weapon is heavy
and i'm not a fan of heavy weapons
only because you have to carry it to
battle but
overall it will kill
thank you
all right gentlemen this is the
sharpness test
the two bar only has one sharp area
which is the axe head so i'll strike
into this side of beef six times with
each of your axes mark you up first are
you ready for this mm-hmm okay
[Music]
your weapon's nice and light for a
weapon that looks as heavy as this is
you can see that this just went right
through
the ribs
this is definitely a cutter
good job thank you chris
you ready let's do it okay
well right off
the weight difference
i mean this thing hits like a ton
these hooks
tear meat coming out the back way
your edge
there's no damage
that i can feel
it's heavy
but uh it does a hell of a lot of damage
nicely done thank you all right
gentlemen this is the strength test now
to test the strength and durability of
your tabar shish bars i'll be using all
parts of it to strike this suit of armor
mark you're up you ready yes i am let's
see it
[Music]
edge is still perfect
no chips no rolling
the hammer gave that armor a nice dent
didn't take any damage
mace is fine
the guy inside there was not happy
all right chris you ready for this don't
hold back
i'm not gonna
this is a heavy weapon
yeah i mean i can control it but
i don't have any rebound
and you've got just the smallest bit of
edge deformation here
other than that
mace is a devastator
you made a beautiful piece thank you i
hope the judges appreciate the
devastation my weapon's capable of
bringing
it's hard to say who's going to win
bladesmiths the judge's deliberation is
complete and there can only be one
forged and fire champion
and that champion is
[Music]
mark congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion thank you
good job buddy thanks
chris
your blade did not make the cut
please surrender your weapons
mark congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion and will be receiving a
check for 10 000 good job
how do you feel right now
i feel great
chris a hell of an opponent
i'm glad it went to the very end i
wanted to see a real competition
mark please present your weapon to the
judges and shake our hands i won i am
the champion
unbelievable
i just won ten thousand dollars my wife
and i we made a deal she gets nine
thousand
and i get a thousand so congratulations
dear
rich matt you've made it to the forge
and fire final
so far we've asked you to design and
produce a weapon of your own choosing
to claim the forged and fire crown you
must design and forge our mystery weapon
one of the most famous and revered
weapons from history
the japanese katana
the katana is the traditional weapon of
the samurai the noble class of warriors
in feudal japan since around 800 a.d the
katana was formed from hundreds of thin
layers of the purest steel available the
quicker draw of the sword was well
suited to combat where life versus death
depended on the weapon you carried into
battle over the centuries the katana has
taken on many mythical properties in
legend and culture from an ability to
slice through other swords to splitting
a hair and it is the sword of choice for
characters in mega hits like kill bill
and the walking dead to measure how your
blades stand up against flesh
doug will cut through these fish rich
yours is up let's put it to the test
nice
it will cut yes it will
it felt
good in a slice
good but the recovery was a little
heavier but it still felt like
it'll give me a close shave good job
okay matt you're up next are you ready
yep
it doesn't cut and i'm a little confused
by that i don't know why it didn't cut
it's got a very good feel to it it's
very light it's got a very nice bounce
to it and
it'll cut
now for the kill test
in this we have a ballistics dummy that
pretty much simulates the human form
organs and tissues
the katana traditionally has a razor
sharp edge
that allows me to find the gaps in
between the armor i'm going to try that
with your blades to see how well it does
rich europe first
[Music]
let's take a look at the damage
the thrust and the slice
went all the way into the internal
organs in here and the kill shot went
deep all the way
into the liver
i think on the kill test
this will kill
okay matt europe
yes
definitely through the laceration he's
disemboweled here
a nice
big puncture in here that definitely
will get the liver
i think it's past the kill test
you both obviously brought deadly
implements of war here
but now it's time to lock and load
gentlemen because for the strength test
we're leaving the forge and we're
heading to the gun range
what
all right gentlemen
this is the final test for the forged
and fire championship
it's the strength test
your weapons will be tested on their
ability to split a bullet
your swords are going to be locked into
a vice
then we're gonna fire a bullet at your
blade
all right matt you ready
break it
three
two
one engage
oh yes
yes
well matt
your sword split a bullet
there's no damage on the edge at all
held up extremely well that is a real
true sign of your craftsmanship thanks
very well done
all right rich you're up next
when i look at him set the gun up and
get ready to shoot that blade
there's a little bit of doubt in the
back of my mind thinking it may not
survive this three
two
one engage
nice
[Applause]
the blade didn't even move
it splits the bullet
i couldn't have been happier there's no
mark on the blade at all held up
perfectly no chipping
everything looks great
thank you
congratulations gentlemen you should be
proud of the work that you've done
which only makes the judge's decision
that much harder we'll see you back at
the forge
matt rich
in just five days you have both forged
elegant and lethal japanese katanas
but in this competition there can only
be one winner of ten thousand dollars
matt
you are the forge to fire champion
congratulations
rich you did not make the cut i wish you
had done a little bit more finish work
you let the handle get a little bit
skinny and it was almost the same
proportions on each side so i know you
ran into a time constraint but it did
split a bullet and that's truly
something to be proud of i feel a little
disappointed but the better blade smith
wants
well matt
congratulations you are the fortune fire
champion you're gonna claim a ten
thousand dollar check how do you feel
this is awesome
your blade is beautiful not only is it
beautiful but it's fast cut so cleanly
through the fish and on the ballistic
dummies that just disemboweled it for
the kill test great job blade aside i
was really impressed with your handle
set up symmetrically it was correct we
get good control good grip on it very
nicely done
this is such a rush i want to drive home
and kiss my son i'm the forging fire
champion
dear [ __ ] knives
deer horn knives are distinctive
double-bladed weapons used as an
extension of the body to counter and
disarm opponents the knives are unique
to the 19th century martial art form
bagua jung students of this discipline
train with the weapon in both hands to
master techniques in slashing and
seizing easily concealed in traditional
chinese garb these mighty knives can be
swiftly brandished to catch an opponent
off guard and deliver deadly cuts with
four horn shaped points the weapons are
notably employed in the film crouching
tiger hidden dragon
to see how lethal your weapon is i will
deliver multiple slashes and thrust on
this pig carcass
steve you're up first you ready
absolutely let's do this
[Music]
oh
well steve you know i was surprised
being that you only have a scale on one
side for the handle and none of the
other it is a rustic look but
nonetheless it is actually comfortable
to hold on to your tips over there sharp
enough to cut easy to thrust with the
bottom and deliver a slice at the same
time
overall your weapon
will kill
yeah
all right nick you're next are you ready
oh yeah
well nick your weapon is very sharp
grabbing your handle it feels smooth
with both scales in there the angles you
have
really
lacerate deeply and overall your weapon
will
kill
good job thank you next up is a
sharpness test to see how sharp your
weapons are i will take your weapons and
deliver multiple slashes and stabs on
this ballistic bag the bag is outfitted
with two posts which simulates blocks or
blows from pole weapons these knives
will encounter in battle
stevie up first you ready yes i am
well steve the points are sharp they
lacerate cleanly it feels good in the
hand i can maneuver this sir will cut
thank you nick you're up next you ready
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty confident
mine can do at least that well probably
better because my points are more
pointier
[Music]
well you can see that it penetrates deep
the angles you have them in and
lacerates out they're comfortable in the
hand and your blades
will cut
thank you next up is strength test tape
to test the strength of your weapons
we're going to clamp them into our
contraption back here once triggered a
staff will strike the center section of
each of the blades one time with a force
of 2 000 pounds
simulating the kind of attacks these
weapons could historically encounter in
combat
steve are you ready yes i am three two
one
in three
two one
yeah well steve i don't see any damage
any rolling of the edge so they held up
beautifully that's great
nick
just waiting for it waiting for it and
one
two three
and i broke the stick
three
two
[Music]
and one broke the stick again
all right well first off let's remember
that the test wasn't about breaking
sticks it was more about how your blade
reacts to being hit by that stick
there is
no damage whatsoever this is still a
razor blade
oh nicely done it thank you well you've
both done commendable work but there can
only be one forged and fire champion in
this competition
[Music]
nick
congratulations you are the forest and
fire champion
steve it's that time please surrender
your weapons congratulations i'm not
surprised at the result there is a
natural
energy that guides all of us throughout
our lives and this is how everything
naturally unfolded unfortunately it
didn't go my way this time but but i'll
be back
nick congratulations you're the fortune
fire champion and we'll be receiving a
check for ten thousand dollars how do
you feel
pretty darn good
awesome good job brother
that's me
that's me the nick that's me i won
i'm going to hug my wife when i get home
and then i'm going to hug my kitty cat
if any of you other bladesmiths out
there
are thinking about it i say do it
try not to have a cold when you do it
though
the partisan
go
the partisan was a late renaissance-era
pole arm used by european armies up
until the early 19th century
roughly six feet long partisans featured
a large blade with a strong medial ridge
and razor edge making it as lethal a
slasher as it was a thruster
the weapon also contained two upturned
branches flared from the base of the
blade which helped the user parry and
even control an opponent's weapon at a
distance
with the onset of firearms pole arms
lost practical use and mostly
disappeared from combat
however the partisan lives on today as
an ornate ceremonial weapon
in a standard fashion for the yeoman of
the guard the bodyguards to the british
monarchs policemen this is the kill test
to test the lethality of your weapon i
will deliver killing blows on this
ballistics dummy
fill you up first you ready for this yes
sir man let's do it
going into this test my heart's starting
to pump a little faster doug's hopefully
just going to destroy this ballistics
dummy
all right phil the design you have here
is
scary
that's a very thick spine you have the
edges are sharp as you can see
very deadly
the one thing about this is that
it's heavy
that is something to take into account
when you're carrying something like this
into battle and you gotta move multiple
times but more importantly your weapon
will kill
thank you sir
all right john your turn are you ready
let's do it
i'm feeling good about the kill test i
know my blade is sharp and i think it'll
cut really well
[Music]
push out a rib
all right john i love the feel of the
blade you can really fight with it
because it's lighter your blade also is
very slim that it penetrates in there
and there's no resistance even enough to
push out a rib
more important i love the balance i love
the feel
and it will kill
thanks sir
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the pike push and armor
stab
now the partisan was often used in
castle or in city defense so to test the
overall strength and construction of
your blades i'll be pushing against
these pikes with the blade and then
stabbing into the armor now this test is
not about what your weapons do to the
targets it's about what those targets
are going to do to your weapons
philip you're up first you ready yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
all right phil this thing is a beast
the weight the shape of your tip really
makes it a good penetrating weapon the
issue i have as the partisan was a
standoff weapon got to be able to
control it
and at full extension
that weight's hard to control
i like the fact that you have this high
medial ridge i like your design
my only issue is the weight
good job thank you sir
john you ready let's do it i am a little
bit worried about the blade going into
the strength test you know stabbing at
armor with the blade being as thin as it
is hopefully it holds up
[Music]
okay john the weapon is light it's well
balanced i really like that issue i have
is down here it looks as if this
is the thinnest spot now you've got a
differential heat treat you can actually
see those lines and that soft core it
may be what's affecting this blade so as
soon as i stabbed in and it locked up
that blade went
with this bend it's not safe to test
this blade anymore it's going to keep on
bending and it's going to get harder and
harder to control
john your blade has suffered a
significant deformation in the course of
our strength testing it's received a
vote of no confidence from the judges
i have to ask you to please leave the
forge
i completely agree with the judge's
decision with the way that blade bent i
wouldn't be comfortable testing it
either
seriously
even though i'm not a fortune fire
champion i am proud of the work i turned
in bill congratulations brother you did
a great job and i'm happy for you
phillip
you are the new forged and fire champion
that's a title that comes with a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
i just one fortune to fire
john you're an awesome dude an amazing
competitor
the sense of joy and accomplishment
knowing my daughter is going to see
there's so many emotions right now
there's i'm overwhelmed i'm trying to
hold back tears man
taking it home to texas
well sean ron congratulations your hard
work has paid off and you are both
moving forward in the third and final
round of competition now at this point
you get to go back to your home forges
for four days using your tools and your
electricity to build this
the sword of mercy
the sword of mercy also known as cortana
has been used as a coronation sword
since the middle ages the ceremonial
blade is defined by its squared blunted
tip legend has it the sword was broken
off by an angel to prevent a wrongful
killing and therefore symbolizes the
mercy it's named for to this day this
benevolent blade is one of the crown
jewels of the united kingdom and is
still in use in coronations of kings and
queens today although even commoners can
see it on display in the jewel house of
the tower of
london basements welcome to the keel
test
run your first you ready for this make
some pork chops
all right ron let's talk about your sort
of mercy here these are sharp chops
each cut was very deep followed by the
nice sweet that's backing up the sword
it cuts deep into this big carcass and
of course as you can see it's easy to
wield and follow through and control
your weapon overall sir your weapon
it'll kill
yeah
all right sean your turn you ready yes
sir let's do this
i'm pretty nervous i know these picks
can be pretty gnarly to blades so i'm
just hoping that mine goes clean through
[Music]
all right sean talk about your sword of
mercy here i'm able to hold on to it i
can tell where the edge is
but your blade sir is not very sharp as
you can see in the first cuts right
there it's more from blunt force trauma
but as you can see with the first six
inches here you have some spots that are
sharp and that sure is what made your
blade
heal
bladesmiths welcome to our strength test
the throne shop
ron you're up first you look excited oh
yeah it's overthrown monarchy
let's do it
all right ron good job edges are still
razor sharp
but that shockwave is traveling all the
way down this blade and
your guard's loose now
but
it was comfortable in the hand
good job thank you
hey sean
how you feeling
awful let's hope you feel better in a
few minutes let's hope
good job
thank you
all right sean it's all in one piece
gotta be proud of that your blade is
still straight this way
not this way
your handle is not loose
but it's definitely separated from the
base of the handle now but like i said
it's still in one piece good job thank
you sir
all right bladesmiths now it's time to
find out just how sharp your weapons are
this is the sharpness test the tapestry
slice
run your first ready oh yeah let's make
it pretty all right let's do it
hold on thank you
all right ron first up
it is loose but it did not affect my
test
overall sir your edge you will cut
awesome
all right sean your turns are you ready
yes sir alright let's do this
all right sean around this area right
here you have some sharp edges so you
can see on the first cut here in this
tapestry it cut in but when i'm dragging
through it just stops its cut
but
it still did cut so
it will cut thank you sir
well bladesmiths has been a good
competition right from the very
beginning but as you know only one of
you guys can leave here with the title
of fortune fire champion carrying a
check for ten thousand dollars now our
judges discussed your blades and i'm not
going to leave you in the dark any
longer
today's fortune fire champion is
ron congratulations
now sean you fought hard you're talented
smith but unfortunately your blade did
not make the cut i'm gonna have to ask
you to please step off the fourth floor
thank you all for having me thank you
good job sean
i thought that the whole thing was sharp
and i guess i was wrong i'm definitely
gonna go home bust out a bunch of knives
and make sure all those suckers are
sharp as hell
ron congratulations that makes you the
fortune fire champion man and you got to
check for 10 000
congratulations
i'm so proud i would encourage anyone to
come and try this experience it doesn't
matter whether you're new to blade
smithing or you're a seasoned veteran
if i can do it at 50 you can do it at
25.
the key long g
the key long g is a chinese pole arm
made famous during the han dynasty in
the second century
over six feet long the key long g
featured a fierce point for stabbing and
slashing the crescent of the weapon was
equally dangerous and could be employed
to dismount oncoming cavalry or tear
away enemy shields a skilled user could
also use the crescent portion to ward
off enemy attacks
however the key long g was at its
deadliest when employed in mass creating
a terrifying spear wall that kept foes
at a distance
the key long g is the famed weapon of
lubu legendary warrior featured in the
television series three kingdoms
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do i will inflict lethal
cuts and thrust on both of these
ballistic stones
jason you're up first you ready yes sir
let's do this
[Music]
that was the coolest thing i've ever
seen all right jason this weapon is fast
it's maneuverable your tip here is sharp
enough to penetrate and lacerate on the
way out
the only one issue here is that it did
pick up a bend but overall your weapon
sir will kill
thanks
all right spicy mike you ready let's do
it let's do this
that's awesome
did i do that
spicy mike you're a kilongji it's wide
enough to break bone as i was thrusting
into the chest cavity it's a light fast
weapon and most importantly it will kill
thank you
all right gentlemen now it's my turn the
strength test to test the strength and
overall construction of your keylon g's
i will be using the crescent part of the
blade to try to break off these spears
then it's onto the drum stab using the
front edge of that blade now remember
this test is not about what your blades
do to the target but what these targets
can do to your blades
all right jason you're up are you ready
yes sir okay
all right jason well this has got some
serious heft to it that bend didn't
change any what i do like to see is the
fact that your edges are just fine it's
a strong weapon definitely did what it's
supposed to do so good job thank you
all right michael you ready yeah
awesome
all right well your weapon is still in
one piece it's still sharp he didn't
lose any of that blade at all it's well
done good one thank you
bladesmiths this is the sharpness test
the banner raise using the crescent's
edge i will cut the rope thereby raising
the banner then i will test your flan
bearish by slicing on the banner
jason you're first you ready yes sir
let's do this
[Music]
it was neat
right jason
your crescent blade is very sharp it cut
cleanly through the rope one and done
the edges of your flamberries are sharp
the tip easily pierced it and sliced all
the way down
overall sir your weapon will cut
all right michael your turn you ready
let's do it let's do this
[Music]
all right mike on your crescent blade
the edge is sharp your flambe is over
here the point is sharp the edges are
sharp it was very easy to slide down
overall sir your weapon will cut
jason michael you guys brought us
exactly what we asked for some
high-performance finale weapons they're
both fantastic
but unfortunately there can only be one
force and fire champion
mike
you are the new forged and fire champion
jason
unfortunately your weapon did not make
the cut
you guys both brought us great weapons
but jason during the kill test your
weapon developed a bend and that's a
structural issue that's why we're gonna
send you home yes sir jason please
surrender your blade i didn't come in
here to finish second i mean honestly
i'm disappointed but i gained a lot
through this process
spicy mike congratulations you are our
new forge and fire champion and that is
the title that comes with a check for 10
000
good job man
this is like the proudest moment in my
entire life well congratulations man you
did some fantastic work please present
your blade to our judges
i'm i won
i'm this crazy guy with a weird nickname
for the middle of nowhere but
i did it
oh what do i do where do i go go get
money okay
i gotta get some stuff paid off but
after that
i gotta think about it
you